me piden que resuelva el valor de t que
despeje el valor de t
en términos del logaritmo en base 10 y
bueno tenemos la siguiente ecuación 10
elevado a la 2 t menos 3 esto es igual a
7 y yo lo que quiero es expresar ante en
términos del logaritmo en base 10 y
bueno lo primero que se me ocurre y creo
que es nos va a servir bastante es
reescribir esta ecuación pero la voy a
escribir utilizando colores si yo digo
que 10 10 elevado a la potencia 2 de
menos 3 2 tm - 3 esto es exactamente
igual y déjeme encontrar este color esto
es exactamente igual que 7 y lo voy a
poner con este color entonces lo que
quiero es despejar al exponente resolver
para este exponente y bueno lo que se me
ocurre es utilizar la definición del
logaritmo en base 10 porque justo eso es
lo que nos piden
y bueno si esta misma expresión la
escribo en su forma logarítmica que me
quedaría bueno que el logaritmo que el
logaritmo en base a 10 en base 10 de
quien bueno en este caso de 7 en este
caso de 7 esto es exactamente lo mismo
que la potencia 2 t menos 3 recuerda que
esto lo podemos leer la siguiente manera
a qué potencia tenemos que elevar 10
para obtener 7 y bueno estos nosotros no
sabemos la potencia la que tenemos que
elevar 10 para obtener 7 es 2 t menos 3
es decir que el logaritmo en base de 10
de 7 es dos veces este menos 3 de lugo
esto utilizando nuestra expresión
equivalente logarítmica nuestra forma
logarítmica y bueno solamente recuerda
que esto tiene todo el sentido lógico
del mundo 10 elevado a la potencia 2 t
menos 3
es lo mismo que 7 que es lo mismo que me
dice aquí arriba
sin embargo lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que ya ha escrito de esta
forma va a ser mucho más fácil poder
resolver para ti esta expresión nos va a
ayudar a poder despejar de aquí el valor
de t que es justo lo que queremos y para
eso qué te parece si sumamos primero
tres de ambos lados de esta ecuación voy
a sumar tres de ambos lados y que voy a
obtener bueno de este lado izquierdo voy
a obtener lo siguiente me va a quedar el
logaritmo el logaritmo en base 10
en base 10 de 7 de 7 ya esto le sumamos
3 ya esto le sumamos 3 y bueno ojo este
3 está fuera de él logaritmo para que no
te confunda hasta que me ponerlo así voy
a poner unos paréntesis y por lo tanto
tengo a esta expresión más 3 y bueno del
otro lado que me va a quedar del otro
lado lo que me va a quedar es lo
siguiente por una parte se va este menos
3 con este 3 y solamente me queda 2
veces éste
ahora yo lo que quiero es el valor de
tema así que qué te parece si te pido
todo entre dos voy a dividir esta parte
entre dos y voy a dividir también esta
parte entre dos de tal manera que estos
dos se van a ir jones y voy a obtener el
valor de temp y déjame escribirlo ya
justo aquí t es igual a quien al
logaritmo en base 10 de 7 ok vamos a
escribirlo justo así al logaritmo a
logaritmo en base 10
déjame ponerlo así en base 10 ok de
quien bueno tengo al 7 al logaritmo en
base 10 de 7 y lo voy a poner con este
color de 7 ok a esto le sumamos 3 así
que déjame ponerlo justo así si a esto
le sumamos 3 y después toda esta
expresión la dividimos entre 2
todo esto lo divido entre 2 así voy a
obtener el valor de t que es justo lo
que me pedían el valor de t expresado en
términos del logaritmo